Lorber Haase
also ich hab zwei Kaninchen im Garten
hatten ihn nicht AP
ob ich was Boyle Tanti 8 alles war dann
die Idee alles lustig was ich gemacht
habe es gibt aber eine Sendung ändert
man wolle fast um um
er die Freundschaft gekündigt das war
das Prozent die Kicks Prozent «Schiffe
versenken» damals
bei fast ein muss um das Heilbronner
Schwimmhalle in Berlin
ich habe auch nie verstanden warum ich
da pro Stunde lang in einem Schlauchboot
sitzen musste
das hat man gemacht weil
er ist dabei nicht
Kostprobe sagt Meier Fado neugierige
habe ich saß mit drei netten Mädels
sind so Schlauchbooten
April ab was machst du hier und sie an
nächster galt die Quoten raus kam
hatten wir beachten Prozent Tagessieger
und Prozent ab kann ich bin jetzt nicht
so toll aber die Leute wollen